Hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with the informative brief for today, Tuesday
, April 6, Spring break is
over Today, more students from
the Clark County School District will
return to class. Grades 4, 5, 7, 8,
10 and 11 return to classrooms for the first time.
time since March of last year also
today elementary students start
full-time in school
those in middle school and
high school will be doing so under the
hybrid model for the rest of the school year
distance learning continues to be
an option for those parents who
The Salvation Army organizations so wish
to deny health centers. They will carry out
a vaccination clinic for the
homeless of the Valley. This will be today from
eight in the morning to four in the afternoon
at the
Salvation Army main station located at 35 Ave.
everyone who makes an appointment will receive the
johnson and johnson vaccine which consists of
a single dose and if you have some
difficulties to arrive with the
necessary supplies for a
newborn babies to see if you want to help they
organized a drive-thru diaper fair
in las vegas tomorrow this
will be at the martin luther king center
located in monkey and kerry from 10
am to one  in the afternoon but attention
you must sign up before at babies 20
points org visit our page language
dotcom diagonal in Spanish for more
information now we move on with
the weather forecast a sunny day is expected
with temperatures lower than
yesterday the temperatures will drop to 80
degrees that  Have a good day I'm
Salí Jaramillo and this was your brief
informative for Disney in Spanish
[Music]